il ya dix ans en 2010 steve jobs a
appelé nick bilton un journaliste à
l'époque du new york times au sujet d'un
article sur l'ipad et pendant la
conversation
nick diaz ou job vos enfants doivent
adorer l'ipad
ce à quoi steve répondent ils l'ont
jamais essayé à la maison on limite les
usages de la technologie par nos enfants
steve jobs soit le mec qui nous a
présenté tous ces outils comme des
outils révolutionnaires
on s'attend à voir sa maison
hyperconnecté les enfants qui
communiquent en mai maugis et on est
loin du compte
et le pire c'est que le cas de steve
jobs n'est pas un cas isolé
chris anderson l'ancien rédacteur en
chef de wired magazine accès nouvelles
technologies assez réputés et
aujourd'hui dirigeant d'une entreprise
de drones a fait des déclarations
similaires
nos enfants ne nous accusent moi et ma
femme d'être des fascistes et d'être
trop occupé par la tech aucun de leurs
amis n'a les mêmes règles que nous et
des cas comme ça il y en a plein melinda
et bill gates n'ont pas laissé leur
enfant à voir des téléphones portables
jusqu alors 14 ans evans qui gueulent le
fondateur de snapshot ne laisse qu'une
heure et demie de téléphone à ses
enfants par semaine
sundar pichai le site de google a
interdit à son fils de 11 ans d'avoir un
téléphone portable et la restreint usage
de la télévision serait bizarre bon que
ces gens qui sont au coeur de la matrice
quelque part prennent de telles
décisions dans leur vie personnelle par
rapport à l'usagé des technologies
la première raison qui ne viendrait à
l'esprit c'est parce qu'ils se rendent
compte à quel point ça peut être
dangereux et c'est ce que confirme chris
anderson nous avons vu les dangers de la
technologie en personne je ne veux pas
voir ça arrivé à mes enfants
alors est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est si dangereux que ça et est ce que
parce que les élites de la silicon
valley le fond on devrait le faire aussi
bonjour à toutes et à tous j'espère que
vous allez bien
aujourd'hui une vidéo que je vous ai
promis dans la dernière vidéo c'est une
vidéo sur l'impact du smartphone sur les
générations à venir et les générations
qui sont même déjà là c'est une vidéo
qui m'a été grandement inspiré par un
article de tes atlantiques qui est sorti
en 2010 est et que j'ai lu il ya
quelques années qui m'a profondément
marqué tous les liens toutes les
ressources extra seront en descriptions
évidemment si vous n'êtes pas abonnés à
la chaîne jeu
invite à le faire c'est gratuit alors
est-ce que l'usagé du smartphone et même
les usages des technologies au sens
large est aussi mauvais que semblent
dire les élites de la silicon valley
pour ça il faut des études des études
assez large
idéalement des études générationnel pour
voir s'il usages des technologies
changent notre comportement d'une
génération à l'autre
zhan twenge est une preuve de
psychologie à l'université de san diego
elle étudie les générations depuis 25
ans elle a agrégé à analyser ses études
dans un livre qui s'appelle à jane qui a
vraiment un titre de merde
vraiment alors ça pue le livre écrit par
un boom 1 mais heureusement nous
n'allons pas juger un livre à sa
couverture
tout ce dont je vous parlais la viande
globalement de quatre études qui sont
faites chaque année aux états unis dans
des classes de lycée et qui compte du
coup plusieurs millions de participants
c'est des études annuelles qui remonte à
1991 1976 et même 1966 je voulais leur
description mais je voulais juste vous
expliquer comment on avait ce genre de
données évidemment c'est des données sur
la population américaine donc ça donne
un regard sur la population américaine
mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit très
différent chez nous pour elle la
différence entre les générations
précédentes c'est des différences de
l'ordre du point de vue de la vision du
monde
alors que là il ya un vrai point de
rupture parce qu'il ya une différence
dans notre manière de passer du temps je
me souviens que quand on était jeunes on
a aussi grandi avec internet msn les wiz
et settat mais déjà il ya une grosse
partie de notre enfance on n'a pas connu
internet et en plus c'était pas du tout
aussi accessible
ça fait quand on allait sur internet
c'était sur l'ordi de la maison l'ordi
familiale y en avait un seul on avait
chacun notre session dessus c'est très
différent que d'avoir son téléphone
personnel à la portée de ses doigts et
avec lesquels on peut se coucher et se
lever
alors comment ça se traduit concrètement
pour elle la génération qu'on va appeler
génération x donc qui est née entre 65
et 79 a essayé d'allonger l'adolescence
en la faisant commencer plus tôt on
l'attend terminer plus tard d'où ce mot
horrible qui vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu d'adulescents à ranger à côté
data chiante
c'est les battant tous célibataires ou
même délicieuse
des mots à battre à coups de
dictionnaires jusqu'à ce qu'ils agonise
pour les jeter dans une fosse commune
qui ne saurait porter non contrairement
à la génération x
ma génération est celle de la plupart
d'entre vous ainsi que la suivante c'est
à dire ceux qui sont nés entre 95 et
ces générations là elles ont essayé
plutôt de retarder le début de
l'adolescence
les jantes 18 en agissant gros comme
agissait les gens de 15 ans je sais pas
à quoi va ressembler l'espace
commentaire mais il est possible que
vous sentiez pas du tout concerné par ça
c'est ok on parle d'un truc
générationnel donc mettez votre ego de
côté et continuer ensemble cette vidéo
alors pour toi une chez cette
contraction n'est pas dû qu'au téléphone
c'est aussi dû au fait qu'aujourd'hui on
valorise les grandes études plutôt que
travailler tôt du coup peut-être que les
parents incitent leurs enfants à rester
étudié à la maison plutôt que de choper
un ta famille temps et en plus de ça vu
que la vie sociale ça se passe là dessus
parce arrangements
cette contraction de l'adolescence on la
constate surtout par un manque
d'indépendance
à l'époque les jeunes voulaient sortir
de chez eux pour pouvoir fumer faire
l'amour à l'arrière de la twingo
il y avait une vraie soif de liberté
d'émancipation
aujourd'hui les jeunes sortent moins et
au moins cette envie d'indépendance par
exemple on a une vraie chute dans les
sorties entre amis pour les quatrièmes
les secondes et les terminales et on a
une vraie chute dans l'obtention du
permis de conduire pour les terminales
c'est pareil aussi côtés d'haïti et sexe
et d'ailleurs le team birth weight le
taux de naissance des femmes de 15 à 19
ans n'a jamais été aussi bas aux états
unis depuis le pic le plus récent en
1991 et enfin cette plus grande
dépendance aussi un facteur économique
car l'indépendance ça un coup et on l'a
vu on n'incite pas forcément les jeunes
à aller travailler
twente chez nous dit qu'aujourd'hui le
terrain de foot le square le parc se
font remplacer par des espaces virtuels
à traire des applications des sites ou
même des gens en ligne comme le montre
cet article sur fortnight où l'auteur
explique qu'en fait quand on joue à fort
nights et pas forcément pour le jeu en
tant que tel mais c'est aussi pour se
retrouver dans un endroit avec ses potes
et on pourrait se dire que si les
nouvelles générations passent autant sur
ces espaces virtuels c'est parce qu'ils
y sont plus heureux
malheureusement c'est faux une étude
dont je vous passe les détails je vous
la met en descriptions qui fait ce lien
entre le temps passé sur l'écran et
l'absence de bonheur alors souvent ces
études là sont pas mal critiqués dans
leur analyse
parce que on ne prouve pas vraiment un
lien de causalité mais plus une
corrélation on ne dit pas que le temps
d'écran rend triste
on dit que les gens qui passent beaucoup
de temps sur leurs écrans sont rice et
c'est très différent
néanmoins il ya une étude qui fait ce
lien alors pas forcément sur le temps
d'écran mais plus sur les réseaux
sociaux
ce qui à mon avis est vraiment la clé du
problème parce que quand on dit que on a
un problème avec ça je pense que le vrai
souci c'est les réseaux sociaux donc on
a demandé à des étudiants qui ont
facebook de répondre à de courts sondage
sur leur téléphone sur deux semaines en
gros on leur a envoyé cinq fois par jour
un lien par sms et devait rapporter
leurs humeurs et combien de temps ils
ont passé sur facebook
le résultat c'est que le plus ils
avaient utilisé facebook le plus il
avait été malheureux mais et c'est là
que c'est intéressant être malheureux
n'a pas conduit à un plus grand usage de
facebook ce qui laisse à penser qu'il ya
un lien de causalité entre le fait
d'utiliser facebook et le fait d'être
malheureux et qu'en plus de salaire
ils n'ont pas cherché à de nouveau être
heureux en allant sur facebook un autre
effet que ça entraîne à un niveau
générationnel encore une fois donc ça ne
concerne pas tout le monde
c'est le sentiment de solitude sentiment
de solitude qui est amplifié d'ailleurs
puisque les rencontres où les soirées
sont documentés sur les réseaux sociaux
genre instagram snap chat etc et donc
ceux qui n'y sont pas qui ne sont pas
invités ou qui n'ont pas pu y être se
sentent encore plus seul et éléments
très intéressants depuis 2007
le taux d'homicide chez les jeunes a
baissé alors que celui de suicides à
monter pour twente vu que les jeunes ont
commencé à passer - temps ensemble ils
sont moins enclins à tuer l'autre est
plus enclin à se tuer soit en 2011 pour
la première fois en 24 ans le taux de
suicide chez les jeunes est passé au
dessus du taux d'homicide alors tous ces
éléments on a vu dans toutes ses études
depuis que je parle des études
générationnel dans cette vidéo
ils sont contestables par exemple le
team bud freight il peut largement donc
cette chute du taux de naissances chez
les femmes de 15 à 19 ans il peut
largement s'expliquer par tout ce qui
est moins un tracé psion par exemple
l'accessibilité à ces moyens là une
génération
elle est soumise à plein de facteurs des
facteurs économiques des facteurs
sociologiques plein de choses
différentes qui sont très difficiles à
analyser et je pense que ce serait une
erreur de tout mettre sur le compte du
smartphone et au delà de ça c'est très
très difficile de faire des études sur
le smartphone le temps passé dessus et
notre niveau de bonheur déjà parce que
ça ne veut rien dire en fait le temps
passé sur téléphone on peut faire
tellement de choses différentes
son téléphone mais même pour les réseaux
sociaux même si on réduit sa juste aux
réseaux sociaux
il ya tellement de manières différentes
de les utiliser que c'est très délicat
de faire des études qui prouvent quelque
chose là dedans il ya notamment une
étude intéressante qui parle de ce point
qui s'appelle the association between
adolescente were being in digital
technology use et qui a été publiée dans
nature
nenshi ils ont pris des études faites
sur le bien-être digital ils ont regardé
toutes les manières possibles d'analyser
les chiffres ils ont montré les
résultats différents que ça pourrait
donner ce qu'on appelle en gros une
spécification curve analysis et il en
conclut que les filles du smartphone est
assez réduit finalement il le compare
même à porter des lunettes par exemple
ou bien aux patates genre les pommes de
terre quoi potatoes donc c'est très
difficile de savoir et d'avoir de
réelles preuves
est ce que le smartphone a détruit une
génération un ski et le titre de base de
l'article de the atlantic
non je pense pas en vrai je pense pas
mais par contre vous avez vu je vous ai
montré toutes ses courbes sur les études
générationnel ce qu'on peut remarquer
c'est que les changements sont abruptes
et paraît évident qu'un objet qu'on
utilise plusieurs heures par jour tous
les jours
surtout à un âge assez jeune a un gros
impact sur nos vies même si j'en ai pas
réellement la preuve alors bannir le
téléphone ne me semble pas être une
solution non plus je toujours été et je
resterai je pense un enthousiaste de la
technologie on vit dans une ère
incroyable mais par contre c'est sûr que
vis-à-vis du temps passé sur les écrans
notamment pour les plus jeunes
je pense qu'il faut appliquer une sorte
de principe de précaution pendant vingt
ans j'ai défendu l'usagé smartphone en
disant que c'était ok que ça donne et
plein d'autres compétences que c'était
pas moins pire que plein d'activités que
les jeunes faisait avant c'est en partie
vrai et c'est en partie faux et en fait
aujourd'hui je me rends compte avec du
recul que je crois que je voulais juste
sonnés progressiste et je voulais pas
faire réac quoi mais sauf que si cette
attitude
elle entraîne une banalisation de
l'usagé du smartphone chez les plus
jeunes
ben c'est pas un progrès c'est plus un
danger quoi du coup voilà avec tous les
doutes qui lie à mettre toutes les
nuances qu'il y apposer sa part et c'est
quand même important vous en parler
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plus
que vous saurez en tirer le maximum
c'est une vision un peu chelou parce que
je vous présente tout un truc
après pour vous dire mais bon en fait on
n'en sait pas grand chose
bon c'est un peu chelou mais c'est un
état de fait bon après ça n'enlève pas
le fait que les élites de la silicon
valley limite énormément usage du
smartphone chez eux et ça n'enlève pas
aussi non plus le fait que adulescents
est un mot pour rubis jane 28 de
bouquins il nomma bhl n'hésitez pas à la
partager
si elle vous a plu je suis actuellement
là tout de suite sur twitch point tv
slash cyrus north pour qu'on parle de
tout ça qu'on échange là dessus je pense
qu'on va on va échanger sur les
premières heures on va parler de ça et
après on va sûrement jouer à des trucs
vous me l'avez demandé aussi j'ai tourné
en watt's in my phone qui arrive
très bientôt ça va être sûrement la
prochaine vidéo
si la portez vous bien love peace ciao